nous le jury en ce qui concerne le
premier chef d'accusation meurtre non
intentionnel au second degré déclarons
l'accusé coupable nous le jury aux chefs
d'accusation de meurtre au troisième
degré perpétrant un acte éminemment
dangereux déclarons l'accusé coupable
nous le jury en ce qui concerne le
troisième chef d'accusation homicide
involontaire au second degré négligence
coupable création d' un risque
déraisonnable déclarons l'accusé
coupable moins d'une journée
c'est ce qui aura suffi au jury pour
délibérer et jugé coupable des règles
chauvine de meurtre au deuxième et
troisième degré et d'homicide
involontaire
soit toutes les charges retenues contre
lui menotté puis écroué dès la
délibération l'ex policier de 45 ans
encourt douze ans et demi de prison
mais pourrait voir sa peine allongées si
le juge conclut à l'existence de
circonstances aggravantes pour la
famille de georges floyd c'est un vrai
soulagement
aujourd'hui nous pouvons à nouveau
respirer
je me sens soulagé d'avoir enfin la
possibilité d'espérer dormir un peu j'ai
dit que j'avais la fois qu'il sera
condamné à l'image de la famille c'est
toute une partie des états unis qui a
accueilli cette décision avec joie des
scènes de liesse ont eu lieu dans
plusieurs villes notamment devant le
tribunal de minneapolis lieu du procès
joe biden a également réagi après avoir
rappelé la famille de djorf l'ojd le
président américain s'est dit soulagé
par la décision de justice
même s'il reconnaît que la lutte n'est
pas terminée rien ne pourra jamais
ramené leurs frères leurs pères mais
cela peut être un pas de géant dans la
marche vers la justice en amérique
[Musique]
soyons également clair sur le fait qu'un
tel verdict est également beaucoup trop
rares c'est le moment pour ce pays de se
rassembler de s'unir en tant
qu'américains nous ne pouvons jamais
être un havre de paix pour la haine en
amérique
derek chauvine doit désormais attendre
huit semaines pour connaître sa sentence
proche de l'implosion sociale il ya
encore quelques mois les états unis
évite une nouvelle décision de justice
controversée mais le combat contre les
violences policières semble loin d'être
terminée